chris rock
on stage
presenting
makes a crack makes a joke about jada
pinkett smith
and will smith is having none of it take
a look
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see it all right
oh wow
wow
so
that is what happens on live
television joining us now et canada's
sangeeta patel i can see it still see it
i think every time we watch this it just
gets even more shocking
i can't i was there watching the show la
la la la was doing his thing offer
cringy moments with the hosts and then
that moment happens i mean first of all
chris rock was killing it right before
that joke i think he was doing an
amazing job there's so much history to
this joke because we know jada pika
smith is dealing with alopecia uh the gi
jane joke was a little bit too sensitive
he made fun of her at the 2016 when he
was the oscar host so this was a
sensitive moment when will went up we
thought it was a joke because he was
actually laughing right before that
moment but something triggered him i
think something was said between jaina
and will at that moment or he saw her
face he went up and legit slapped chris
rock got off and and the cursing and the
way this was handled i mean i think a
lot of people lost respect for will
smith this is gonna be a smudge on his
his career this is the moment we're
gonna be talking about will smith going
forward i don't know if he's ever gonna
do an interview the problem is with this
whole situation is when you have a show
like red table talk where you're so
sensitive and very open about your
relationship and your family this is
gonna happen this is what comedians do
the way he handled it with the slop was
not the way to do it and uh it's
unfortunate because it was a big night
for him
yeah there was a moment sangeeta i think
everybody watching last night thought
what's going on here was this a plan but
then they uh you know will i think the
second time that he approached uh chris
everybody was like okay this is for real
what's uh happening what's going on
right now and then remarkably not long
after all of this
will's back up on stage accepting his
oscar for best actor
yeah and this was like anything after
that was overshadowed i don't even know
who won
but like the fact is his speech we were
all waiting we were all standing there
for him to apologize to chris work or
apologize for the moment something but
he did say some quotes that kind of
referenced it he said i want to
apologize to the academy i want to
apologize to all my fellow nominees art
imitates life i look like the crazy
father just like the one being said in
richard williams but love will make you
do crazy things and then he quotes
denzel washington who said
at your highest moment be careful that's
when the devil comes for you so he kind
of referenced it but not really
apologizing and then he went to a vanity
fair party with his family i think he
should have took a moment and not gone
to the party i know it was a big night
for him but uh the fact is this morning
there are reports that lapd did talk to
chris rock he's not charging him so
let's see what happens but it's
unfortunate it happened but man what a
night